et retour à new york d'abord où la vie
reprend donc c'était la rentrée donc pas
seulement pour la bourse mais aussi pour
les écoles ici on fait très attention
aux enfants au fait qu'ils ont vu et
revu ces images très violentes on parle
beaucoup avec eux et puis c'est
l'occasion aussi de serrer les rangs
avec le patriotisme toujours en valeur
phare donc la rentrée des écoles
reportage depuis mardi le jour du drame
plus d'école pour carlier isabella et
quand elles font un dessin c'est un
drapeau américain
avec leurs mots d'enfant elle dit
vouloir aider les autres à se sentir
mieux
qu'est ce qui est arrivé les tours se
sont écroulés les gens ils se sont
enfuis et cela ils ont sauté par la
pluie
chez les souris en scène les trois
enfants posaient beaucoup de questions
sur la catastrophe
omni présence envahissante impossible de
ne pas y répondre de s'y soustraire
ils n'ont pas compris l'extrême violence
de cet acte ils ont compris la tristesse
de ce drame
toutes ces vies anéanties à cause de
tout cela je pense que l'amérique va
dire au monde très fermement
êtes vous avec nous ou contre nous car
il ne peut pas y avoir de demi mesure
c'est blanc ou c'est noir le patriotisme
c'est sans doute aujourd'hui puisqu'il
est encore le ciment de millions
d'américains marqués dans leur chair
en ce lundi l'important pour les enfants
sorenson et les autres petits américains
c'est de revenir à l'école même s'ils
savent que rien ne sera plus tout à fait
comme avant